courtney first and foremost
congratulations on the season two we are
very excited i really dig this show a
lot talk to me about how amazing it'll
feel to receive a little emmy love for
this thing
oh my god that would be incredible yeah
i mean the show was so good
all of a sudden i wrote 13 pages i don't
remember writing i'm good
i found my views okay put the axe down
talk to me about season two what do you
what do you hope to explore with this
character what are you excited for you
know i was so lucky to
be able to explore what i was able to in
season one and i can only imagine that
it's going to be even more but you know
everything from
addiction to mental health to
marriageal
marital strife to you know moving and
a writer's block i just had so many
things to play having teenagers one
going through puberty one
you know pushing mom away which i'm i'm
very
comfortable with
or going through but so
uh i just had so much it was so
multi-faceted my character and and i'm i
imagine there's going to be more because
at the end of last season i was
heading right into a psych ward so i
have a feeling
a second your daughter sends you to a
psych ward what's your real life
daughter what does coco think when she
sees a scene like that
yay
good job now who knows um
i don't know that that was really that
was i i can't even imagine what's going
to happen i mean it's it's it they're
it's it's
um limitless it really is i mean and
jeff astrolf is just spinning his wheels
all the time they've already gotten the
writer's room together and sharon horgan
is incredible and
so i feel really lucky well listen we
look forward to it bring it all we love
all this content talk to me about a
dream guest star possibility who is
there anybody on your radar anybody you
could dream of hope for
um
oh my gosh
i mean you know we
judith the light came on and now she
will not be a guest star but she will
actually be a series regular i'm sure
she's incredible um i mean so many
actors that i would love to work with i
mean obviously the ones i've already
worked with but i think that might be a
little different we're on the warner
brothers lot i walked through this
building we're in the tour building do
you get nostalgic from all your time on
the friends set when you come on this
lot does it bring you back at all
absolutely we've on stage five which is
where friends started
is where the attic is of of you know
yeah my characters um where she writes
and where rosemary visits her and
so yeah it's it's it's great now but you
know i just hope that when we come back
it's
you know without mass i hope i just hope
it's more you know i want the commissary
to be open i don't mean the one i just
want to sit in the same seat that we
used to sit in and get the same salad
and
um that's what i'm hoping for
um all right i'll let you get out here
in a second but not before i ask i am i
am thrilled uh for the next installment
of scream
you ready
for this
never mi i'm an absolute fanboy we know
hayden peniter is attached uh
i heard that today i heard that i know
that you guys got a script what are the
chances i i what are the chances we get
sydney and gail back together the group
the whole gang what do you think
uh you know i don't know about contracts
and where things are but i mean i tell
you in the script it's a really good one
it's great i cannot you know they don't
let you i don't even
you actually have to be killed if you
talk about it so i'm just going to not
say anything
you